[Musik]
wir haben aufgerufen ihr habt uns mehr
als 1000 fragen zum corona virus
zugeschickt und die meistgestellten
wollen wir heute beantworten und damit
hallo zum logo extra corona eure fragen
ja diese fragen werden aber nicht von
mir beantwortet sondern von diesen
experten dem logo extra mit dabei ärztin
marilyn ag
sie forscht für das universitätsklinikum
hamburg-eppendorf an einem corona
impfstoff außerdem stellt sharif der
bildungsministerin aus rheinland-pfalz
stefanie huber ich eure fragen und live
zugeschaltet aus berlin ist der
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
seit wochen ist das leben von uns allen
auf den kopf gestellt und irgendwie
dreht sich fast alles um corona
aber wie hat das mit dem corona virus
eigentlich angefangen und wie ist es
hier nach deutschland gekommen das
wollen viele von euch wissen und hier
kommt die antwort
zuerst trat das neuartige corona virus
das die krankheit kubik 19 auslöst in
der chinesischen stadt wuchern auf die
ersten menschen hatten sich anfang
dezember angesteckt sie sollen auf einem
großen markt gewesen sein auf dem fisch
fleisch und auch lebende wildtiere
verkauft wurden
forscher gehen davon aus dass das corona
virus dort von tieren auf den menschen
übertragen wurde
in der millionenstadt wuchern konnte
sich das virus schnell ausbreiten
durch geschäftsleute und touristen
gelangte es dann nicht nur in andere
teile chinas sondern verbreitete sich
auf der ganzen welt auch bei uns in
europa
viele haben vermutlich nicht einmal
bemerkt dass sie sich mit dem corona
virus angesteckt hatten entweder weil
sie gar nicht krank geworden sind andere
weil es bis zu 14 tage dauern kann bis
die ersten krankheitszeichen auftreten
also zum beispiel husten und fieber
forscher auf der ganzen welt arbeiten
mit hochdruck daran medikamente und
einen impfstoff gegen das corona virus
und cupid 19 zu entwickeln
noch haben sie ihr ziel aber nicht
erreicht eine expertin die hier in
deutschland nach einem impfstoff gegen
das corona virus sucht ist die ärztin
marilyn ado sie ist in hamburg und von
dort aus redet sie mit uns gute namen
frau otto guten abend ich habe es gerade
eben schon erwähnt sie suchen ja nach
einem impfstoff gegen das corona virus
lorenz fragt wie lange dauert es noch
bis es einen impfstoff oder eine medizin
gibt
wir haben da muss man sich noch ein
bisschen gedulden wir arbeiten wirklich
mit vielen wissenschaftlichen teams sehr
sehr intensiv dran und auch tag und
nacht zum teil aber er wird
wahrscheinlich erst ende des jahres
einen impfstoff zur verfügung haben den
man vielleicht schon weiter anwenden
kann
leon fragt kann man corona nur einmal
oder mehrmals bekommen wir kennen das
virus ja erst seit dezember
und wir wissen doch ganz viele sachen
nicht so genau allerdings geht man davon
aus dass wenn man es einmal gehabt hat
dass man ein antikörper also immunzellen
oder immunantworten entwickelt und nicht
unmittelbar wieder infiziert werden kann
wie lange man dann immun ist so nennt
man das das wissen wir noch nicht aber
wir gehen davon aus wahrscheinlich
mehrere monate vielleicht sogar jahre
und viel wie möchte wissen wie lange
bleibt das corona virus eigentlich auf
oberflächen
ja das wird momentan sehr viel geforscht
man hat im labor gesehen ist es
vielleicht sogar sechs bis neun tage auf
oberflächen sein kann
aber normalerweise sind diese versuche
spiegel nicht die wirkliche möglichkeit
wieder es gibt noch keine übertragungen
die nachgewiesen ist zum beispiel von
der türklinke und insgesamt muss man ja
sagen auch da hilft händewaschen
also ganz häufig die hände waschen ist
sicherlich einer der besten
schutzmöglichkeiten gegen das virus
marie fragt kann das corona virus auch
über lebensmittel übertragen werden
auch das ist noch nicht gezeigt worden
man kann sich natürlich vorstellen wenn
jemand auf einen apfel nist und man
denen dann direkt da rein weiß dass man
sich so auch infizieren könnte aber
genau da ist es ähnlich wie das obst
waschen was man normalerweise auch
machen würde also ganz normale
hygienemaßnahmen lebensmittel waschen
hände waschen das hilft auch daten beim
schutz
die nächste frage beschäftigt wirklich
viele kinder und zwar bekommen auch
tiere das virus zum beispiel haustiere
also man muss jetzt keine sorge haben
dass man über seinen hund oder seine
katze mit dem corona virus angesteckt
wird und muss auch keine sorge haben
dass man selber die haustiere anstieg
mit dem chor unter virus das ist bisher
nicht belegt insofern ist das etwas wo
man sich keine großen sorgen darüber
machen sollte wie schützen sie sich
eigentlich vor dem virus das also das
medizinische personal das mit diesen
patienten arbeitet dass wir das trägt
schutzkleidung und ich habe die
schutzkleidung mitgebracht also wir
tragen brillen schutzbrillen atemmasken
nach haube wir haben einmal kittel und
handschuhe und das ziehen wir alles an
bevor wir zum patienten reingehen und
wenn wir aus dem zimmer wieder
rauskommen dann ziehen ist alles wieder
aus und so schützen wir uns vor
tröpfchen und vor ansteckung mit dem
virus prado vielen dank für das gespräch
sehr gerne vielen dank das interview
haben wir heute vor einer stunde
aufgezeichnet seit drei wochen sind ja
in ganz deutschland die schulen dicht
auch dass damit sich das corona virus
nicht so schnell ausbreitet die schulen
sind geschlossen das lernen geht aber
weiter und zwar bei jedem von euch
zuhause für mehr als acht millionen
schülerinnen und schüler hat sich der
alltag in den vergangenen wochen sehr
verändert
die schulen sind geschlossen die
klassenräume leer
stattdessen wird zu hause gelernt ja
also in der schule ist von einfacher da
kann man ja dann fragen stellen wir mal
nicht weiter weiß und dann kriegt man
auch ist gut erklärt von den lehrern
aber hier dann zu hause sagt man
eigentlich an seine eltern aber wenn
dies nicht wissen oder will nicht weiter
wissen dann schicken wir eigentlich eine
mail dann die lehrer ich finde das gar
nicht gut dass wir den schulstoff jetzt
zuhause bearbeiten müssen weil die neuen
grammatiken und generell der schulstoff
wird jetzt immer schwieriger und ich
muss sie mir teilweise einfach selbst
erschließen im moment i miev passen
erwähnen der hofpause immer fußball
spielen
ich finde das homeschooling eigentlich
voll in ordnung aber wenn er zum
beispiel der drucker kaputt geht und man
sich einen neuen kaufen muss haben uns
mal die aufgaben erledigen kann so über
uns das ist dann halt schon blöd also
läge das besser als die schule werbung
stoff her ist es einigermaßen gleich und
ich kann jedes mal ausschlafen muss ich
so früh aufstehen wie welchen schulen
müssten ja das mit dem ausschlafen kann
ich richtig gut verstehen das war bei
mir nicht anders
trotzdem wollten viele von euch wissen
wie geht es weiter mit der schule
diese und andere fragen habe ich hier
hergestellt stefanie grubich die
bildungsministerin von rheinland-pfalz
also los geht's lia fragt kann man schon
sagen ob die schulen nach den
osterferien wieder öffnen
nein das können wir im moment noch nicht
sagen wir warten einfach auf den rat der
expertin experten die sich angucken wie
sich die infektion in deutschland zu
bewegen ob das weniger werden und wenn
die uns grünes licht geben dann können
die schulen wieder an den start gehen
hirn fragt was passiert mit den themen
die nicht geschafft werden kommen die
dann nächstes schuljahr
das fängt so ein bisschen von dem thema
ab wenn man das braucht um dann wieder
weiter darauf aufbauen zu können dann
muss man das spätestens im nächsten
schuljahr sozusagen am anfang noch mal
wiederholen oder überhaupt neu befragt
wonach werden wir dann dieses schuljahr
getötet also das ist ein punkt bei dem
wir uns eben im moment gedanken machen
und so wie das im moment aussieht wenn
wir
noch arbeiten schreiben können weil die
schon wieder offen sind dann werden die
natürlich mit benotet und wenn nicht
dann wird man natürlich gucken was so im
ersten halbjahr passiert ist denn ein
halb der schule hat ja schon voll
stattgefunden und noch ein bisschen
danach also dann wird man einfach gucken
wie man da eine ordentliche note fürs
zeugnis hinbekommt paulina eine ganz
interessante frage und zwar fragt sie
was machen die lehrer in dieser zeit die
lehrer im moment sind zum teil in der
schule weil wir eigentlich in allen
bundesländern notbetreuung haben für die
kinder deren eltern wichtig sind weil
sie zum beispiel im krankenhaus arbeiten
weil sie im lebensmittelladen arbeiten
also die im moment arbeiten müssen und
dann sind viele eben in der schule und
ein teil ist zu hause aber macht quasi
auch unterricht von zu hause mit die
rufen an bei den schülerinnen und
schülern die geben aufgaben die
konzipieren neue hausaufgaben die
korrigierende geben wieder eine
rückmeldung also die sind alle ganz gut
eingespannt stimmt es dass vielleicht
die schulen bis zu den sommerferien
geschlossen bleiben
das wissen wir nicht stimmt es dass die
sommerferien vielleicht ganz gestrichen
werden nein das stimmt nicht
stimmt es dass wenn die schulen wieder
geöffnet werden dann alle tests und
klassenarbeiten auf einmal geschrieben
werden nein er ständig
wenn jemand sagt ich vermisse die schule
dann sagen sie das kann ich gut
verstehen das tut mir leid aber so sind
die zeiten im moment man kann seine
freundinnen und freunde und auch seine
lehrerinnen und lehrer im moment nicht
so treffen wie wir das gewohnt sind aber
es wird sich auch wieder ändern wenn
jemand sagt wenn das so weitergeht
werden die das schuljahr wiederholen
müssen dann sagen sie nein wir wollen
nicht dass schülerinnen und schüler das
schuljahr wiederholen sondern wir werden
lösungen finden dass möglichst viele
einfach weiter durchstarten können ins
nächste schuljahr und das keiner
nachteil hat was möchten sie diesen
vielen schülerinnen und schülern da
draußen mit auf den weg geben jetzt
gerade in dieser zeit also ihr lieben es
ist keine leichte zeit für euch das weiß
ich das ist auch für die eltern nicht
leicht und übrigens auch für die
lehrerinnen und lehrer nicht leicht das
ist eine schwierige zeit und so eine
zeit haben wir in deutschland noch nie
erlebt ich finde aber dass alle ziemlich
klasse managen und ziemlich
verantwortungsbewusst sind und deshalb
kann ich euch nur sagen nutzt die zeit
gut wechselt euch ein bisschen ab lernen
bis den sport zu hause und freut euch
einfach drauf es werden wieder andere
zeiten kommen ich finde er macht das
eine ziemlich klasse und ihr werdet
keine nachteile haben
frau ruhig vielen vielen dank der sich
zeit für uns genommen habe er gerne mit
der schule kann es also erst weitergehen
wenn sich das corona virus in
deutschland nicht mehr so stark
ausbreitet dafür müssen alle plätze
weiter so menschenleer aussehen wie
dieser hier in berlin
wie die situation in deutschland gerade
so ist wir bringen euch kurz auf den
neuesten stand
[Musik]
die zahl der menschen die sich in
deutschland mit dem corona virus
infiziert also mit dem virus angesteckt
haben nimmt noch immer zu
bis heute nachmittag waren es offiziell
85 1903 infizierte 1122 menschen davon
sind gestorben
aber 22 1440 menschen gelten
mittlerweile als wieder geheilt
in ganz deutschland gibt es weiterhin
ausgangs beschränkungen das soll auch
mindestens bis zum zwanzigsten april
noch so bleiben auch die meisten läden
cafés und restaurants bleiben vorerst
geschlossen die menschen sollen abstand
halten und zu hause bleiben
experten haben heute gesagt dass all
diese einschränkungen tatsächlich wirken
und dass sich das virus in deutschland
jetzt wohl ein bisschen langsamer
ausbreitet entwarnung konnten sie aber
noch nicht geben
es bleibt also wichtig dass jetzt alle
weiter mitmachen
einer der jeden tag mit den vielen
experten kontakt hat und die situation
hier in deutschland mit ihm bewertet ist
der bundesgesundheitsminister also der
oberste gesundheitspolitiker in
deutschland jens spahn aus berlin ist da
jetzt live bei uns in der sendung guten
abend herr spahn
wir haben es eben gehört mittlerweile
gibt es mehr als 85.000 menschen die mit
dem virus infiziert sind in deutschland
wir haben richtig viele fragen von
kindern bekommen zum beispiel fragt anna
warum gehen die ansteckungen nicht
zurück sondern werden täglich mehr
obwohl jeder zu hause ist ist eine gute
frage hanna das kommt daher dass es
immer ein bis zwei wochen dauert bevor
überhaupt erkannt wird oft dass jemand
infiziert ist also dass jemand dann
getestet wird der test dann positiv ist
wie man sagt und dann geht er in die
statistik das heißt diejenigen die wir
jetzt heute zum beispiel zusätzlich
haben die fälle in der statistik die
gerade gezeigt wurde die über 80.000 die
haben sich wahrscheinlich vor ein bis
zwei wochen infiziert
und deswegen sehen wir eben erst
zeitverzögert tatsächlich dass jetzt
diese maßnahmen auch wirken aber wir
sehen die steigerung pro tag geht zurück
wir haben vorher auch schon die ausgangs
beschränkungen angesprochen und gefragt
werden die ausgangs beschränkungen zu
ausgangssperren also könnten die regeln
noch strenger werden dass man eigentlich
gar nicht mehr raus darf
das sehe ich im moment nicht es ist auch
gar nicht schlimm im übrigen draußen mal
spazieren zu gehen das ist jemand steckt
sicher nicht an wenn man alleine oder
mit den eltern spazieren geht muss er
zusammen mit den eltern in einem
haushalt oder ich mit meinem mann oder
andere mit ihren partnern jeden tag eng
zusammen wenn man also mit denen mit dem
mann zusammen wohnt auch mal spazieren
geht dann ist das sogar eher gesund auch
mal an der frischen luft zu sein
wichtig ist eben nicht zu viel kontakt
mit anderen zu haben und vor allem nicht
in der größeren gruppe auch unterwegs zu
sein ich weiß das feld gerade schwer vor
allem wenn man die freunde dann nicht so
häufig sehen kann wie sonst aber draußen
sein
das ist wenn man allein unterwegs ist
mit der familie unterwegs ist kein
problem wir haben auch gesagt bis zum
zwanzigsten april gelten ja erstmal
diese regeln und hermine möchte gerne
wissen müssen wir nach den osterferien
noch zu hause bleiben wir sehen schon
dass es besser wird das ist ja gerade
auch gesagt worden in dem beitrag das
also die zahl der infektionen singt aber
wir können noch nicht sagen ob es
sozusagen weit genug
runter geht jetzt auch mit den
neuinfektionen das werden wir erst in
den nächsten tagen bis ostern sehen und
dann wenn wir nach ostern auch schauen
in der politik und wir werden uns auch
beraten lassen wie es dann in der woche
na also nach den osterferien dann dann
weitergehen kann und dann ob man
schrittweise eben zurück in den alltag
kommt eins ist glaube ich schon klar es
geht nicht sofort alles wieder los nicht
jedes fußballspiel nicht jede party jede
veranstaltung aber die frage ob zum
beispiel kindergarten und schule wieder
losgehen können die ja auch wichtiger
sind als die partys das wird sich dann
sicherlich stellen
das heißt wenn nach dem zwanzigsten
zwanzigster april schrittweise etwas
passiert dann wie gesagt nur in
portionen und nicht alles auf einmal
genau wenn dann schrittweise
und dann fangen wir im zweifel erst mit
dem an worauf er weniger gut verzichten
können und wo die risiken auch für die
gesundheit am geringsten sind
viele versuchen ja auch die risiken für
ihre eigene gesundheit zu minimieren und
gerade wird ja viel diskutiert ob so ein
mundschutz dabei helfen könnte und lena
hat dazu folgende frage wird es bald
pflicht sein eine schutzmaske zu tragen
zum beispiel in österreich im moment wo
wir insgesamt sowieso alle wenig kontakt
zu anderen haben außerhalb der eigenen
familie ist das aus meiner sicht nicht
nötig was ist aber ein unterschied macht
ist ganz wichtig so eine selbst genähte
masken der maske die man sich selbst
bastelt eine stoffmaske die man im
einzelhandel kauft die schützen nicht
vor allem selbst sondern sie schützt
andere vor einem wenn wir reden dann
wünsche ich jetzt ja auch dann gucken
wir ein bisschen immer dann kommt
röckchen raus oder wenn wir niesen
husten und so eine maske auch wenn es
eine stoffmaske ist die reduziert dass
die bringt das auch nicht auf null
natürlich kommt im zweifel immer noch
was durch aber es ist weniger und das
schützt dann andere und wer zum beispiel
dann doch mal in die u-bahn in dem bus
muss oder eben doch auch mal einkaufen
geht dann kann das eben helfen dass
andere sich nicht infizieren ich finde
nur wichtig dabei zu sagen eben so eine
maske anders als eine maske die die
pflegekräfte tragen schützt nicht den
der sie trägt vor allem sondern die
anderen ersparen vielen vielen dank dass
sie heute live mit dabei waren wir
konnten leider nicht alle fragen
beantworten aber vielleicht gibt es ja
noch mal eine andere chance ich komme
gerne wieder
danke schön so damit sind wir auch schon
am ende vom logo extra ich hoffe wir
konnten viele eurer fragen beantworten
wenn ihr noch mehr wissen wollt dann
schaut mal auf logo de vorbei dort haben
wir ganz viele erklärvideos und
informationen zum corona virus für euch
so und damit sage ich bleib gesund hier
lieben bis bald macht's gut und tschüss
[Musik]